reims en champagne s'est dit si la cité
des rois que nous avons choisi de suivre
le gr 654 qui est aussi le chemin de
saint jacques de compostelle pour nous
rendre avait gelé en bourgogne
ce haut lieu de pèlerinage sera notre
terminus entre les vignobles champenois
et les coteaux bourguignon dans ses
beaux paysages
nous avons visité des lieux parfois
insolites est fait de rencontres
atypiques la cathédrale marque le départ
de notre parcours
datant du xiiie siècle notre dame de
reims est inscrite au patrimoine mondial
de l'unesco depuis 1991
c'est qu'ici que presque tous les rois
de france ont été sacrés pour cela on
appelle rens la cité des sacres
nous admirons dans ce lieu de culte les
magnifiques vitraux de grands artistes
comme chagall qui sublime la lumière
dans une architecture gothique des plus
belles de france
au milieu des touristes des pèlerins de
compostelle viennent faire valider leur
carnet de route
la credencial peut-être les croisons
nous sur notre chemin
un dernier regard sur les 2300 trois
statues qui ornent la cathédrale et
c'est sous l'oeil de jeanne d'arc que
nous partons à travers rens
sur le bord du canal de l'aisne à la
marne nous trouvons notre première
balise
nous sommes sur la bonne voie
nous suivons ce chemin le long du canal
très fréquenté des rémois et des
péniches
notre promenade nous conduit vers un
château un établissement mythique au
coeur de reims
construit en 1904 par le marquis de
polignac
il est discrètement lové dans un parc de
7 hectares à la végétation verdoyante
à l'intérieur un restaurant une table de
prestige dans un lieu décorées de
meubles rares dans une atmosphère très
française
en cuisine le chef c'est philippe mille
en 2009 il a reçu les titres de bocuse
de bronze et champion de france de
cuisine artistique en 2011
il obtient le titre suprême pour un chef
meilleur ouvrier de france pendant 15
ans philippe mille a fait ses armes dans
les plus prestigieuses maisons comme le
meurice le ritz la sphère et autres
philippe recherche les produits locaux
aux goûts et aux saveurs d'antan pour
recréer une cuisine authentique
pour moi le futur la cuisine c'était la
cuisine il ya peut-être 100 ans
si on revient vraiment sur les bases sur
le goût le produit en lui même coin pour
faire découvrir aux clients justement ce
retrouver ses parfums qui a peut-être
coûté il ya trente ans mais qui se
souvient du bois c'est vrai j'avais
oublié une tomate c'est pas une tomate
anodine qui les tient goudeau c'est une
tomate aussi tuer quelqu'un beaucoup de
parfums un peu sucré beaucoup de goût
avant de partir philippe nous offre une
recette qu'il affectionne et qui fait la
joie de ses clients le cabillaud faso
filippe et au champagne
vous préparez un petit dos de cabillaud
en habit noir
ça va être une année dans les
champignons on a récupéré région qu'on a
fait c'est chez nous mène c'était qu'on
a réduit en poudre et on ajuste le panis
le rouler dedans quand nous ont dit on
en jute lever la partie la plus dure en
fait plus ferme
et puis on va la farcir avec un autre
champion de paris et notre jambon des
ardennes jean moisset réservés et puis
ensuite on va les mettre à griller à la
cheminée est à oublier tout doucement
donc là en 2000 et les jaunes d'oeuf
avec un peu de champagne n'est plus ou
moins clairement manqué un sabayon
pertes ont souhaité et on va les purs
plus doucement sur la plaque on
s'affaire cerf-volant en complément se
passe le côté gras qui va faire les
grands bandits sur le cabillaud qui va
être nacré lui dire tu frottis et ça ça
va arrondir un peu ce poisson est en
plein de petites choses qu'on a fait du
jus de viande on se jure on va juste y
ajouter le vinaigre de reims pour
acidifier légèrement ce jus que ce soit
un peu plus désagréable a ajouté avec ce
cas bio voilà reste que le poisson
moi j'estime être un petit papier
cuisson pour été que ça colle de trop au
fond du plat donc là on voit que le le
beurre commence à prendre quelle
coloration
on va y ajouter d'autres morceaux de
cabillaud et bien voilà on va la rosée
et le cuire doucement
voilà le thé lieu sous peu
il est temps pour nous de quitter la
ville de reims pour les coteaux de
champagne
nous arrivons au village de verzy les
randonneurs du club rando reims sont là
aussi en balade
nous décidons de les suivre et de faire
un bout de chemin avec eux nous sortons
du village car ils veulent nous montrer
une particularité de verzy les faux de
verzy
direction la forêt domaniale qui
surplombe le village dans cette forêt de
hêtres
certains ont des formes étranges
recroquevillés sur eux mêmes comme
d'immenses banzaï
on les nomme les faut c'est être
tortillard sont plus d'un millier c'est
la principale réserve de fonds mondial
le mystère de ces êtres est entier
autrefois on parlait de punition divine
de magie de malédiction mêmes l'on
disait que la forêt serait habitée par
des démons malgré tous ces arbres
étrange sont depuis des décennies
protéger et soigner grâce à eux une
ambiance particulière règne dans la
forêt nous voilà maintenant dans les
vignes de verzenay ici on ne produit que
du champagne et cela depuis le 9e siècle
là nous faisons la connaissance de
delphine qui s'affairent dans les rangs
elle inspecte les pieds et prépare sa
vigne pour la prochaine vendange
delphine nous propose de découvrir les
caves familiale est suivie d'une petite
dégustation de champagne
une invitation qui ne se refuse pas
delphine et son frère éric ont repris
l'entreprise familiale depuis dix ans
mais cela fait plus de deux cent
cinquante ans que la famille russo
élabore du champagne verzenay mon
travail avec des cépages traditionnels
et de les cépages de champagne pinot
noir et chardonnay le pinot noir va nous
donner des vins à c'est assez corsé
assez assez rond
le chardonnay ma nous apporter une
petite note fruitée une petite acidité
qui va donner un bon équilibre au vin
puisque dans la majorité de nos
assemblages on va retrouver entre 20 et
30 % de chardonnay et le reste en pinot
noir
delphine et eric exploite huit hectares
de vignes 60% de leur récolte est vendue
à de grandes maisons de champagne mais
le reste leur permet quand même de
produire 40 mille bouteilles de
champagne grand cru sous leur propre nom
on compte environ deux ans entre le
moment où va le récolter effectivement
et le boire et même plus d'années si on
se réfère en fait aux assemblages
puisque l'assemblage c'est l'essence
même du champagne s'est mélangé
plusieurs années plusieurs cépages afin
d'obtenir un vin toujours de qualité
identique
et comme toutes les visites de caves
cela finit dans une dégustation mais
avait redonné sur les coteaux dominant
le village un phare se dresse au phare
sur la montagne de reims
nous décidons d'en savoir plus et il a
été érigé en 1909 par un négociant en
vins en fait un vigneron qui voulait
promouvoir son champagne d'une façon
originale et donc il a érigé un phare au
milieu d'une mer de vignes c'est ce
qu'ils disaient c'était joseph goulet et
il ya bâti sur le site un restaurant une
guinguette un théâtre de plein air et
donc rémois et sparnacien venu ici avec
le train qui s'appelait le cdr à
l'époque la compagnie des chemins de fer
de la banlieue rémoise
venez sur le site faire la fête boire le
champagne joseph goulet est monté en
haut du phare lors de la première guerre
mondiale
le phare étant parties bombardées car il
faire d'observatoire toujours debout
envahi par la végétation
il restera oublié jusqu'au début des
années 90 le parc naturel régional de la
montagne de reims est une collectivité
le reste hors effet de lui en 1999 le
musée de la vigne
ce n'est pas amusant
10 ionel comme on peut l'entendre c'est
un centre d'interprétation donc on
l'appelle le phare alors une visite du
musée dure 1h30 elle et audio guidées et
on aborde différents thèmes sur le
terroir de champagne et la vigne c'est
une visite qui qui est pédagogique à la
fois et ont gardé victimes en musique
nous quittons la montagne de reims pour
rejoindre châlons en champagne
la préfecture de la marne cette ville ne
manque pas d'attrait de par son
architecture et ses monuments pour
quelques temps nous devenons des
touristes et découvrons la ville face à
la statue de jean talon le premier
intendant de la nouvelle france le
québec se dresse la collégiale de notre
dame en vaux qui est aussi un point de
passage pour les pèlerins de compostelle
puis notre chemin passe par la haute
marne près du plus grand lac artificiel
d'europe le lac du der avec près de 50
kilomètres carrés et 350 millions de
mètres cubes d'eau ce lac créé en 1974
est d'abord un réservoir pour que paris
ne soit pas inondée en hiver et ne
manque pas d'eau en été mais pour le
réaliser il a fallu sacrifier d'abord
trois villages et déplacé ses habitants
en 1999 à sainte marie du lac nuisement
un musée a été créé pour retracer la vie
des trois villages aux outils certains
bâtiments des anciens villages ont été
démontés et remontés ici alain son
directeur fait partie de ceux qui sont à
l'origine de ce projet dans la cuvette
il y avait trois villages qui ont été
engloutis
1 le village de chantecoq celui de
champaubert hautbois et celui de
nuisement au bois
quand on a créé le lac tous les
bâtiments des trois villages ont été
détruits par le feu
sauf quelques bâtiments dont cette
église démonter pièce par pièce et
reconstruit à environ quatre kilomètres
de l'endroit où il était à l'origine
chaque année des anciens habitants des
villages comme l'outil gêne dans cette
petite église où une messe leur est
donnée cette église représente pour eux
un lieu du passé certains s'y sont
mariés
d'autres y ont été baptisés il renoue
ainsi avec leurs souvenirs d'antan afin
de ne pas les oublier
les années passant le lac du der est
devenu un lieu de vacances et de loisirs
avec ses 77 km de rivage
il a mérité le nom de la mère en
champagne malgré le tourisme le lac est
aussi un site ornithologique de renommée
internationale en l'espace de quarante
ans la nature en a fait un écosystème
original tout nouveau et puis on peut
calculer la richesse de cette de cet
écosystème en comptant le nombre
d'oiseaux qu'on peut observer à l'année
et on est à plus de 260 3 espèces
observées par an avec bien évidemment le
l'oiseau emblème du lac c'est la grue
cendrée avec quasiment plus de cent
mille oiseaux qui passent à chaque
voyage de migration
nous voici dans l'aube au village de
soulaines ici le trésor c'est la terre
c'est l'argile de soulaines
au début du 20e siècle l'argile faisait
vivre sont des tuileries dans la région
aujourd'hui la tuilerie artisanale de
jean louis est l'une des deux dernières
à exister à tuléar existe depuis 1850
donc je suis la cinquième génération et
on utilise le matériel de la troisième
génération large ils ont l'appui zain km
donc dans le finage de soulaines et elle
revient dans la fosse pour la fabriquer
ensuite elle est moulé au travers d'une
machine qui date de 70 ans une moule
deux mises à sécher la terre faut
qu'elle sache pendant trois semaines
ensuite une fois que tout est bien sec
on enfourne les pièces dont dans le four
que vous voyez derrière moi un des
derniers plus grands fours de france ont
tué au bois et au charbon on enfourne
cinquante mille pièces à la main quand
ses cuisses change de couleur ce que la
terre elle contient de l'oxydé de fer
celle oxydes de fer qui réagissent ou la
cuisson c'est une terre suite naturelle
on rajoute absolument rien dans l'oubli
connais aussi les techniques ancestrales
agréés par les monuments de france
il a participé à de nombreuses
restaurations comme le baptistère
saint-jean à poitiers où il a dû recréer
des carreaux datant du ivème siècle
les architectes le savent
cet artiste petit est capable de
travailler à la demande sans limite de
quantité
ça peut être des briques
100 briques nous sommes une brique
l'argile de soulaines a encore de beaux
jours devant elle une nouvelle demande
apparaît les briques de terre crue
deviennent très prisé dans les
constructions écologiques notre route
maintenant nous entraîne dans l'yonne en
bourgogne dans la petite ville de
tonnerre dans la vieille ville un lieu
insolite nous attend là sur le chemin
des pèlerins incrustés au milieu des
maisons
il y à un gouffre mystérieux d'où
jaillit une eau bleue toute l'année
c'est la fosse dionne et nul ne connaît
l'origine de cette sens
c'est pas une source de type résurgente
on l'appelle une science vauclusienne
alors on pense que ça vient des
infiltrations d'eau dans les roches un
petit peu partout mais en tout cas pas
de sources aux alentours puisqu'elles
ont été teintées et rien n'est ressortie
donc ça fait partie du mystère de la
fosse dionne lors de plongée souterraine
les spéléologues n'ont pu aller plus
loin que 360 mètres de longueur et 60
mètres de profondeur les étroiture de la
galerie l'argile en suspension la force
du courant et surtout la profondeur les
ont fait renoncer
ces dernières années lors de différentes
tentatives trois plongeurs ont péri
depuis les plongées sont interdites les
légendes demeure ce serait une entrée de
l'enfer il y aurait aussi le basilic et
ce serait peut-être lui qui aurait causé
leur perte
le basilic c'est un serpent mythique qui
foudroie ce qui
ce dont il croise le regard donc la
fosse dionne tuer les sens et le basilic
est censé être au fond du gouffre et
quand on s'approche cette vieille
croyance a sûrement quelque chose de bon
car elle tient les enfants de tonnerre à
distance mais le secret de la fosse
dionne reste entier et cela pour très
longtemps encore
nous reprenons la route dans la campagne
bourguignonne va loin de tonnerre à
meaux l'homme nous sommes attirés par de
drôles d'oiseaux
nous sommes ici dans une ferme
pédagogique
les animaux de la ferme sont bien tous
présents dans un enclos à l'écart
josiane la propriétaire a pour son
plaisir choisi d'élever des animaux pour
le moins peu commun sont des émeus la
même sorte que les autres chats
originaire du même pays c'est à dire que
ceux là sont originaires d'australie
c'est un loisir que je trouve très très
original et pas du tout agressif
concernant contrairement je veux dire
éventuellement aux autres qui sont
beaucoup plus grosse et le mal est plus
agressif c'est en visitant un élevage
que josiane a craqué pour cme en 1999
elle en acquiert 16 et tous se sont très
bien adaptées aux climats bourguignon ce
plus grand oiseau du monde après
l'autruche mesure entre un mètre
cinquante et un mètre quatre-vingt-dix
pèse de 30 à 45 kg le courir jusqu'à 55
km heure et surtout n'est pas un animal
fragile
il peut vivre entre 40 et 50 ans et ce
gentil volatile a une particularité il
exprime ses émotions par de curieux sont
c'est un peu comme un tam-tam parce que
leur peau c'est un cuir et d'anti maître
de l'air dans leur gorge sac était comme
une vibration
ici les prochains locataires seront des
lamas ou des alpagas l'eau gr 654 notre
chemin de randonnée repasse par les
vignes mais ici ce sont celles de
chablis gilles et son fils romain font
leur inspection journalières l'été est
en avance le raisin mûrit vite
cette année les vendanges vont être
précoce
nous les suivons afin d'en savoir plus
sur ce vin blanc
l'un des plus connus au monde le domaine
collet est connu à chablis depuis plus
de 200 ans et de père en fils on
travaille la vigne le châble et c'est
uniquement du vin blanc issu d'un seul
cépage qu'elle chardonnay c'est un vin
blanc sec qui s'accompagne avec les
poissons ou les crustacés par exemple
des saint jacques ou même des asperges
vertes en entrée ou des huîtres pour le
petit chablis bon le vignoble de chablis
comprend 5500 état et il y a dix neuf
communes aux alentours de chablis qui
ont droit à l'appellation le petit sable
y est l'une des quatre appellations du
terroir il y aussi le chablis le chablis
1er cru et le chablis grand cru
gilles et romain exploite 40 hectares et
travail les quatre appellations
mais si le chablis est si différent par
rapport aux autres vins blancs cela
vient surtout du sol on a des terres
assez calcaire avec une spécificité
c'est le kimméridgien qui est ce sont
des huîtres fossilisés et c'est grâce à
ça qu'on va retrouver la typicité la
minéralité des vins de chablis chablis
en en mono cépage cépage chardonnay du
chardonnet il s'implante dans tous les
pays producteurs du monde et il ya qu à
chablis où on arrive à retrouver cette
minéralité cette tension dans les vins
le chablis le vin blanc le plus copié et
contrefaits au monde partout le nom
chablis est devenu synonyme de vin blanc
aux etats-unis par exemple demandé un
verre de chablis et l'on vous servir un
verre de vin blanc mais ordinaire
conscient de sauvegarder le patrimoine
gilles et romain partagent tous de
l'idée d'une agriculture raisonnée
pour preuve déjà huit hectares de vignes
sont en bio et pour cela romain étudie
toutes les possibilités comme élever un
vin plus longtemps afin d'avoir une
stabilité naturel sans nuire à la
qualité le sur l'île
le chemin des vignobles nous amène à
quelques kilomètres de là a offert la
quatrième grande ville de bourgogne
nous traversons la vieille ville afin de
nous rendre à un lieu bien connu des
randonneurs la maison des randonneurs
une bonne adresse au coeur de la ville
ici on peut poser ses sacs à dos ces
vélos et faire une pause avant de
repartir
le gérant c'est laurent et il est ici
depuis sa création en mai 2006 en fait
c'est l'idée d'un élu de la ville de ce
faire un jean paul rousseau qui a
lui-même fait le chemin de saint-jacques
et puis qu'il s'est rendu compte que la
ville de fer offrait pas une bonne
prestation au pellerin il y avait des
pèlerins qui avait plusieurs centaines
de pèlerins qui traversait la bourgogne
et puis à auxerre ils recevaient pas un
accueil digne d'une préfecture
alors donc jean paul rousseau à celle ci
s'est démené pour trouver un budget et
puis réaménager ses bâtiments qu'ils
avaient avant une affectation
différentes c'est de lanciers lieu de
résidence du scientifique ministre paul
bert que la maison des randonneurs a été
créé tout ça dans un parc public de 6000
mètres carrés au coeur de la ville alors
maintenant c est un gîte d'étape de 25
places 8 125 places et pèlerins qui
arrivent ici sont très très agréablement
surpris de trouver un tel niveau de
prestation les gîtes d'étape avec les
dortoirs
avec un fusil et d'un côté qu'un garçon
de l'autre puis quoi le mieux c'est
terminé maintenant toutes les chambres
une salle de bains
ces deux nuits maximum alors c'est vrai
qu'on est placée en centre ville c'était
une volonté de la municipalité ne pas
faire de concurrence aux hôtels
il est l'un des barques à l'improviste
et en droit généralement on leur a
réservé on garde toujours un ou deux
lits pour les pèlerins de passage
nous décidons aussi de passer la nuit
dans ce superbe gîte et nous auront même
droit à une chambre avec vue sur le parc
après une bonne nuit de repos
notre parcours vers vézelay nous emmène
à méry sur yonne et là nous décidons de
prendre de la hauteur sur les rochers du
saussois dominant l'yonne et le hameau
du ce soir avec leurs 50 mètres de haut
ces falaises de calcaire font la joie
des écoles d'escaladé ce site est
reconnu pour être un haut lieu de
l'escale à d'international
mais nous nous voulons juste admirer le
magnifique panorama d'ailleurs nous ne
sommes pas les seuls les randonneurs du
club terre de légendes ont eu la même
idée que nous
notre dernière et à cébazat remet à 30
km de vézelay ici il y un petit
restaurant très connu pour sa carte
faite uniquement des spécialités
bourguignonnes et préparé comme à la
maison
pour nicolas nos cuisiniers le terroir
n'a pas de secrets et les clients
raffolent surtout de son boeuf
bourguignon
aussi il concocte toujours avec la sauce
une petite entrée traditionnel et bien
classique en bourgogne les oeufs en
omelette
je vais vous faire des heures meurette
spécialités bourguignonnes cdo prochaine
ont rendu la rouge avec la sauce
bourguignonne
on attend que le vin rouge choix à
frémissement versa les halls dans le vin
rouge
k
pendant la cuisson de vérifier ce qu'il
faut c'est juste que le blanc soit cuit
le jaune reste liquide
vous sera qu'une petite personne
reste plus qu'à apprécier comme tout le
monde
notre chemin de compostelle arrive à
régler la fin de notre parcours fait un
village médiéval perché sur une haute
colline que l'on appelle la colline
éternelle avec moins de 500 habitants
vezeau les reçoit des visiteurs qui
viennent du monde entier pour une chose
la basilique sainte marie madeleine
un million de personnes franchissent ses
portes chaque année au 10ème siècle les
reliques de sainte marie madeleine la
première à qui le christ ressuscité est
apparue sont apportés avait gelé la
basilique est alors construite
immédiatement les pèlerins du monde
entier s'y rendent ce chef-d'oeuvre
darroman est l'un des tout premiers à
avoir été classé patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco
si un homme connaît bien l'histoire de
ce lieu c'est monseigneur ricard
le recteur de la basilique de plus c'est
un enfant du pays
ici il a même était enfant de choeur il
ya une attirance lorsque les gens font
c'est une expérience si je puis dire une
expérience spirituelle et qui fait que
qu'ils soient croyants ou non croyants
il ya quelque chose qui passe j'ai fait
une petite chapelle dédiée tout temps
entièrement à saint jacques
pour que les pèlerins viennent prier à
cette chapelle de saint jacques
et puis ils peuvent se recueillir ils
viennent le matin après l'office un
événement d'une grande intensité a eu
lieu dans la basilique à la fin de la
dernière guerre en 1946 une croisade de
la paix fut organisée afin de réunir 14
pays européens engagés dans la guerre et
par cela sceller l'amitié des peuples
chaque pays a fait porter une croix par
ces pèlerins désole quand des
prisonniers allemands captif dans la
région ont eu vent de cet événement
spirituel
ils ont demandé à se joindre à la
procession est d'amener aussi leur croix
plus de trente mille personnes s'étaient
déplacées pour la procession
ce jour là monseigneur ricard était un
enfant et il se souvient
les quatorze croisant arrive et puis
soudain l'émotion générale on a vu
arriver les prisonniers allemands avec
leurs croix et 7 crois hélas toujours au
milieu de nous et tout récemment encore
les autorités françaises et allemandes
sont venus se recueillir dans cette
croix de réconciliation
mais la basilique n'est pas juste un
lieu de visite de pèlerinage est avant
tout une église c'est une église
paroissiale avec toutes les activités
paroissiales se marier avec un bébé
c'est beaucoup de gens si j'écoutais
toutes les demandes qui je marierai
toute la france répond bien au delà
les avant de partir vers d'autres
aventures il ne faudrait pas oublier
l'essentiel et ne plus vénérés dans ce
lieu les reliques de sainte marie
madeleine conserver dans sa crypte sous
la basilique